peter parker the kid wonder spider-man
himself he's an amazing young man
he's a dancer a triple threat a golfer
and hang on
what's up bro hey dude how you doing
dude it's so late
you're in the uk i'm yeah i'm standing
in my parents house and they're asleep
in there
so i can't i have to be quiet
so we started shooting spider-man 3
a few months ago which has been crazy
and really weird because we're shooting
it back in atlanta and
that's where i did my audition for
spider-man and we're actually shooting
in the stage that i did my audition
oh so it's like a really weird full
circle story of like
walking through the same door i walked
through as an 18 year old kid like
nervous like oh my god i hope i get this
job
and then walking through the door at 24
making the third movie
loving life confident enjoying
everything that's happening to me
so it's been amazing dude it's been
awesome i've been very lucky
i know a lot of people around the world
have had a really hard time um
and that's why it's amazing that we have
people like you i'm looking down here
you've raised thirty two thousand
dollars tonight alone
it's amazing dude that's so cool so
we've raised
thank you it's awesome man i'm so i'm so
chuffed you asked me to be a part of
this i'm really really really grateful
and happy